The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue to
offer high quality educational
resources for free.
To make a donation or view
additional materials from
hundreds of MIT courses, visit
MIT OpenCourseWare at
ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: Alright.
Well, we've been looking in the
last couple lectures at a
really important topic
in thermodynamics.
Which is, how do you tell
what's going to happen.
Which way does a process
want to go?
Which way will it go
spontaneously?
And if it goes in one direction
or another, where
does is lead?
In other words, what is
the equilibrium state?
And this is just an incredibly
important area that
thermodynamics allows
us to speak to.
So we started to see this.
Sort of direction of
spontaneous change.
And where the equilibrium
lies.
So what we did is, remember we
started with the second law.
Right?
That dS is greater than
dq over T. And for the
spontaneous change which happens
irreversibly That
means that'll be dq
irreversible.
It would be equal for
the reversible case.
And we combine this with first
law, which for the case of
pressure volume changes
we write as this.
And so what this gave us was
a very, very useful general
criterion for determining
whether something happened
spontaneously.
Namely, du plus p external dV
minus T for the surroundings
dS, is greater than zero.
Sorry.
It's less than zero.
And this is for any spontaneous
change.
If it equals zero, then
we're at equilibrium.
And if it's greater than
zero, then the process
goes the other way.
We would write the process in
the reverse to have it be less
than 0 and it would
go spontaneously.
And based on this one result,
we then looked under various
constraints and said OK, what
about looking at our
variables, volume, pressure,
temperature, other things,
entropy, if we constrain those,
what's the condition
for equilibrium?
And that's what led us to a
number of results to determine
what quantities we even
need to be looking at.
To figure out equilibrium.
And what the conditions were.
And so what we discovered
were the following.
This one, which we already
had seen, which is dS, is
greater than zero.
Change in entropy is
greater than zero,
for an isolated system.
We also saw that dS for constant
H and p was greater
than zero. du, regular energy,
at constant entropy and volume
is less then zero.
And u is minimized
at equilibrium.
And this is the familiar
result from ordinary
mechanics, where you're not
worrying about something like
entropy for a whole collection
of particles.
That is, you minimize potential
energy and you see
things falling under the force
of gravity and so forth, going
to potential energy minima in
conformance with this result.
dH, S and p is less than zero.
So our H is u plus
pV, as you know.
And H is minimized
at equilibrium.
And this is, of course, with
constant S V. This is
constant S and p.
But of course, the need to have
entropy constrained is
never going to be the most
convenient one experimental.
There may be circumstances under
which it's the case, but
it's often difficult
to control.
On the other hand, temperature,
volume and
pressure are variables that are
much easier in the lab to
keep constant.
To keep control over.
And so that led us to the
definitions of other energy
quantities, the Helmholtz
and Gibbs free energy.
We discovered that the quantity
dA, under conditions
of constant volume
and temperature,
is less than zero.
And A is u minus TS.
And A is minimized at
equilibrium, under conditions
of constant T and V. And
finally, and in many cases the
most important of the results,
because of the conditions it
applies to, we saw that this
Gibbs free energy is less than
zero, that's our condition
for spontaneous change.
Where the Gibbs free energy,
u plus pV minus
TS is H minus TS.
Also A plus pV and G is
minimized at equilibrium with
constant temperature
and pressure.
And that's why the Gibbs
free energy is just
so enormously important.
Because so much of what we do
in chemistry does take place
with constant temperature
and pressure.
So we have this condition
that's established in a
quantity that we know
how to calculate.
That tells us the direction
of spontaneous change for
ordinary processes, chemical
processes, mixing and you name
it, under conditions that are
easy to achieve in the lab.
OK, now what we'd like to do is
be able to calculate any of
these quantities in terms of
temperature, pressure, volume
properties.
That is, in terms of
equations of state.
For any material.
Then we would really be able to
essentially calculate anything.
Anything thermodynamic.
About a material.
Of course, that's assuming we
know the equation of state.
We may or may not.
But because in many cases we can
reasonably either model or
measure equations of state,
collect data for a material
for its temperature, pressure,
volume relations, then in fact
if we can relate all these
quantities to those, then in
fact we really can calculate
essentially all of the
thermodynamics.
For the material.
So let's relate the
thermodynamic quantities to
equation of state
p, V, T data.
And we can do that by going
through and deriving what
we'll call the fundamental
equations of thermodynamics.
that'll provide these
relations.
And at this point we know
enough to do this in a
straightforward way.
So if we start with a relation
for energy, T dS minus p dV.
Where u is written
as a function
of entropy and volume.
And we've seen that that's
generally the case.
It comes from the fact that dq
reversible is T dS, and dw
reversible is minus p dV.
And of course du is
the some of those.
So, this is generally true.
Since these are all
state functions.
That is, this is derived in the
case for reversible paths.
But since these are all simply
state functions and
quantities, this is
generally true.
Now we can use it to derive
differential relations for all
of the thermodynamics
quantities.
So let's just go through
and do that.
So H is u plus pV.
So dH is just du plus
p dV plus V dp.
And now we're just going to
substitute du in here.
And the p dV terms are
going to cancel.
So we have the result that
dH is T dS plus V dp.
Right?
And that shows us that H is
written naturally as a
function of entropy
and pressure.
And now let's keep going.
A is u minus TS.
dA is du minus T
dS minus S dT.
We're going to do
the same thing.
Substitute this for du.
This time, the T dS terms
are going to cancel.
So we have dA is minus
S dT minus T dS.
That can't be right.
And it isn't.
Minus S dT, that's the p dV term
that's left, minus p dV.
And it shows us that A is
written naturally as a
function of T and V. G,
we can write in any
of a number of ways.
Let's write it as H minus TS.
So dG is dH minus
T dS minus S dT.
Here's dH.
We'll substitute that in,
and the T dS terms
are going to cancel.
So dG is minus S dT plus V dp.
And this shows that G is
written naturally as a
function of T and p.
So these, which we will exalt
and celebrate by our
sparingly-used colored chalk,
are our fundamental equations
of thermodynamics.
So what they do is, they're
describing how these
thermodynamic properties change,
in terms of only state
functions and state variables.
Very, very useful.
And that's what it means, when
we say well, it's natural
then, to express say, G as a
function of T and p, that's
what we're saying.
Is that we can express
its changes in
terms of these variables.
Related only through
quantities that are
functions of state.
I don't need to know about
a specific path here.
If I know about the states
involved, I just need to know
what the volume was
in each of them.
Now, before, of course, in the
first part of the class we
started out looking at u and
then looking at H not as
functions of S and V or S and
p, but as functions of
temperature, mostly.
In general, temperature and
volume or pressure.
And it doesn't mean
that something was
somehow wrong with that.
It certainly is, it still is
going to be useful to do
thermochemistry.
To ask questions like how much
heat is released in a chemical
reaction that takes place
at constant temperature.
Not one of these variables.
And we can calculate that.
So it's not that we're somehow
throwing away our
ability to do that.
However, the thing to remember
is, when you look at heats of
reaction under those
conditions it's
all well and good.
But it doesn't tell you, this
is the direction that the
reaction is going to go.
It doesn't tell you, this is the
equilibrium concentration
that you'll end up with.
That doesn't come out of what
we calculated before in
thermochemistry.
What does come out, which is
very useful is, if you do run
the reaction, here's how
much heat comes out.
And if you want to run a furnace
and provide energy,
that's an extremely important
thing to be able to calculate.
Because you're going to run it
and you'll probably find
conditions under which you can
run it more or less to
completion.
But it doesn't tell you,
by itself, which
direction things run in.
Whereas under these conditions,
these quantities,
if you look at free energy
change, for example, at
constant temperature and
pressure, you can still
calculate H. You can
still calculate
the heat that's released.
This is what will tell you
under some particular
conditions what will
actually happen.
Where will you end up.
Very, very important, of
course, to be able to
understand that.
Now, it's also very useful to
look at some of the relations
that come out of these
fundamental equations.
And they're straightforward
to derive.
So, all I want to do now is look
at the derivatives of the
free energies with respect
to temperature
and volume and pressure.
So for example, if I look at A,
which we now have written
as the function of T and V, of
course, in general I can
always write dA as partial of
A, with respect to T at
constant volume dT, plus partial
of A with respect to
V, at constant temperature dV.
And I know what those
turn out to be.
It's minus S dT minus p dV.
So what does that tell me?
It tells me that the partial
of A with respect to T at
constant V is minus S. Right?
In other words, now I know how
to tell how the Helmholtz free
energy changes as a function
of temperature.
Or as a function of volume.
dA/dV, at constant T, must be
negative p.
Things that I can measure.
So I can in a very
straightforward way say, OK,
well, here is my Helmholtz
free energy.
If I'm working under conditions
of constant
temperature and volume,
that's very useful.
Now, if I want to change those
quantities; change the
temperature, change the volume,
how will it change?
Well, I can, for any given case,
measure the pressure,
determine the entropy and
I'll know what the slope
of change will be.
Similarly for G as a function of
temperature and pressure, I
can go through the
same procedure.
That is, it's easy to write down
straight away that dG,
with respect to temperature at
constant pressure is minus S.
That is, this is, dG/dT
at constant pressure.
And this is dG/dp at constant
temperature.
So again with the Gibbs free
energy, now I see how to
determine, if I change the
pressure, if I change the
temperature by some modest
amount, how much is the Gibbs
free energy going to change?
Well, it's easy to see.
These two relations involving
entropy are also useful
because they'll let us see
how entropy depends
on volume and pressure.
And let me show you
how that goes.
Now, you've already seen
how entropy depends on
temperature.
We've already seen that, going
to write dS as dq reversible
over T. And it's Cv dT over
T at constant volume.
It's Cp dT over T at
constant pressure.
So we know that dS/dT at
constant volume is Cv over T,
and dS/dT at constant pressure
is Cp, over T. And we've seen
that on a number of occasions.
So that tells us what to do
to know the entropy as the
temperature changes.
But now, what happens if,
instead we look at what
happens when we go to some state
one to some other state
two and it's the pressure.
Or the volume, that changes.
And by the way, just to be
explicit about this, let's
take this example, it means that
delta S, if we undergo a
change from, say, T1 to T2.
There's Cp over T dT.
So it's Cp log of T2 over T1,
and we saw this before.
So now, instead, let's
look at some process.
State one goes to state two.
Let's have constant T. And
look at what happens if
pressure goes from p1 to p2.
Or volume goes from V1 to V2.
And see what happens there.
We looked at pressure change
before, actually, in
discussing the third law, the
fact that the entropy goes to
zero as the absolute temperature
goes to zero for a
pure, perfect crystal.
But, actually, we didn't do
that in a general way.
We just treated the one case
of an ideal gas as the
temperature is reduced.
But we can do this, generally,
by using what are called
Maxwell relations.
And all this is, is saying that
when you take a mixed
second derivative, it doesn't
matter in which order you take
the two derivatives.
So, let's, we're going to
use this relationship.
And we're going to
use these two.
So, using those, now, what
happens if we take the second
derivative of A, the mixed
derivative, partial with
respect to T and the partial
with respect to V. So let's
leave these off for a moment,
and now let's try that.
And the point is that the second
derivative of A, with
respect to V and T in this
order is the same as the
second derivative of
a with respect to T
and V in this order.
It doesn't matter which order.
But that turns out
to be useful.
So let's do this explicitly.
Which means we're going to
take the derivative with
respect to volume of dA/dT.
Now, the dA/dT isn't
constant volume.
The derivative we're taking with
respect to volume, when
we take that it's at constant
temperature.
But what is it?
Well, we already know what
dA/dT at constant V is.
It's negative S. So this
is negative dS/dV.
At constant temperature.
Now let's take it in
the other order.
So d/dT of dA/dV,
just like this.
The dA/dV is calculated at
constant temperature.
We know it.
Then we can take the derivative
of that quantity,
when we vary the temperature,
holding the volume constant.
But again, dA/dV dT,
there it is.
It's negative p.
So this is just negative dp/dT
at constant volume.
These things have to be
equal to each other.
Because these mixed
second derivatives
are the same thing.
But that's very useful.
Because this is what comes
directly out of an equation of
state, right?
You know how pressure changes
with temperature at constant
volume if you know the
equation of state.
It relates the pressure,
volume,
and temperature together.
So from measured equation of
state data, or from a model
like the ideal gas or the van
der Waal's gas or another
equation of state,
you know this.
Can determine how entropy
is going to behave
as the volume changes.
If we try that for an ideal
gas, pV is nRT.
So dp/dT at constant volume,
it's just nR over V. And that,
now, we know must equal dS/dV,
with a positive sign.
At constant temperature.
So now let's try looking
at something where
are V1 goes to V2.
The volume is going to change,
and we can see
how the entropy changes.
So, if one goes to two and V1
goes to V2, and it's constant
temperature, just what we've
specified there.
Delta S is S(T, V2) minus S(T,
V1), T's staying the same.
So it's just the integral from
V1 to V2 of dS/dV At constant
temperature dV.
And now we know what that is.
So it's nR integral from V1 to
V2 dV over V. So it's nR log
V2 over V1.
There's our delta S. So we
know how to calculate it.
Make sense?
Now, we can do the same
procedure for
the pressure change.
And all we do is, I'll just
outline this, I think.
I won't write it all
on the board.
But, of course, it's going to
come from the fact that these
second derivatives
are also equal.
So d squared G dT dp is equal
to d squared G dp dT.
In other words, the order of
taking the derivatives with
respect to pressure and
temperature doesn't matter.
And what this will show is
that dS/dp at constant
temperature, here we saw how
entropy varies with volume,
this is going to show us how
it varies with pressure.
Is equal to minus dV/dT
at constant pressure.
And again, this is something
that comes from
an equation of state.
We know how the volume and
temperature vary with respect
to each other at constant
pressure.
That's what the equation
of state tells us.
So, again, I can just
use that result.
So, if we do a process where
one goes to two at constant
temperature, and now the
pressure, p1, goes to p2, well
then delta S is just the
integral from p1 to p2 of
dS/dp times dS, so
it's just this.
And so of course it's
still pV equals nRT.
So now we just have
nR over p dp.
Right?
So we're going to see
the same story.
It's nR log of p2 over p1 for
the process where there's a
pressure change.
Any questions about this part?
So what we've done is take
one step further.
We've used the fundamental
equations that are hiding down
here, out of sight but
never out of mind.
And what we've done is look at
the derivatives of the new
free energies that we've just
recently introduced, A and G.
And then, the only thing we've
done beyond that is say, OK,
well now let's just take the
mixed second derivatives, they
have to be equal
to each other.
And what's fallen out when we do
that, because in each case,
one of the first derivatives
gives us the entropy.
Then the second derivative gives
the change in entropy
with respect to the variable
that we're differentiating,
with respect to which is either
pressure or volume.
And the useful outcome of all
that is that we get to see how
entropy changes with one of
those variables in terms of
only V, T, and p, which come out
of some equation of state.
And all we did, further, is take
that second derivative.
That mixed second derivative.
And, of course, see that either
way we do that we'll
have an equality.
Now, let's go back to our older
friends u and H. Which
we've expressed now in terms
of S and V, S and p.
So, so far we don't have a way
to just write off, relate them
to equation of state data.
Which also would
be very useful.
Here, A and G, we've already
got as functions of these
easily controlled, conveniently
controlled state variables.
Let's look at those quantities.
u and H. And look
at, for example, the
V dependence of u.
The volume dependence.
And in particular let's look
at, for example, du/dV at
constant temperature.
Now, we can immediately
see what du/dV at
constant entropy is.
Experimentally, though, that's
not such an easy
situation to arrange.
Of course, this is a much
more practical one.
But it doesn't just fall out
immediately from the one
fundamental equation for du.
But we can start there.
So, du is T dS minus p dV.
And I can take this derivative.
du/dV at constant
T. And so, what is it?
Well, it's not just p because
there's some dS/dV at constant
T. This isn't zero.
There's some variation, dS/dV,
at constant temperature.
That's going to matter.
This part, of course,
is just minus p.
But we just figured out what
dS/dV at constant T is.
This is dp/dT at constant
V. So that's neat.
So in other words, we can write
this as T, dp/dT at
constant V, minus p.
Let's just check T, p, T, V, p.
Right?
In other words, we just
have pressure,
temperature and volume.
Again, if we know the equation
of state, we
know all this stuff.
So again, we can measure
equation of state data.
Or, if we know the equation of
state from a model, ideal gas,
van der Waal's gas, whatever,
now we can determine u.
From equation of state data.
Terrific, right?
So let's take our one model that
we keep going back to.
Equation of state, and just
see how it works.
That is, ideal gas.
And see how it works
with that.
Now, we saw before, or really
I should say we accepted
before, that for an ideal
gas, u was a function of
temperature only.
Well, now let's try it.
So, dp/dT, for our ideal gas,
at constant volume,
remember pV is nRT.
So this nR over V. And then,
using the relation again, we
can just write this as p over
T. In other words, we're
taking advantage of
the fact that we
now know that quantity.
In the case of the ideal
gas, we just have a
simple model for it.
More generally, we
could measure it.
We could just collect
a bunch of data.
For a material.
What's the volume it occupies
at some pressure and
temperature?
Now let's change the pressure
and temperature and sweep
through a whole range of
pressures and temperatures and
measure the volume in
every one of them.
Well, then, we could
just use that for
our equation of state.
One way or another, we can
determine this quantity.
For the ideal gas it's this.
So now our du/dV, at constant T
is just T times dp/dT, which
is just p over T minus
p, it's zero.
Remember the Joule expansion.
And we saw that, you saw that
the Joule coefficient for an
ideal gas was zero.
So that you could see that for
the ideal gas, u would not be
a function of volume, but
only of temperature.
But actually, when you saw that
before, you weren't given
any proof of that.
It was just that when the
good Mr. Joule made the
measurements, to the precision
that he could measure, he
discovered that for some gases
it was extremely small.
At least, smaller than anything
he could detect.
So it sure seemed like it was
going to zero, under ideal gas
conditions.
And that was the result that
we came to accept.
Here, though, you can just
derive straight away.
That for an ideal gas it has to
be the case that there's no
volume dependence
of the energy.
Only a temperature dependence.
It's the same for H. Just like
u, we'd like to be able to
express it in a way that allows
us to calculate what
happens only from equation
of state data.
But, again, our fundamental
equations show us how it
changes as a function of
entropy and pressure.
So, dH is T dS plus V dp.
So let's look at dH/dp.
We know how to get it
immediately if we
keep entropy constant.
But we'd like to relate it to
what happens if we keep the
temperature constant.
So then, just like we saw,
analogous to what saw just
before, it's T dS/dp at constant
T. Plus V. But now
we've seen from the Maxwell
relations that dS/dp is minus
dV/dT, for constant p.
Again, this is this quantity,
one of these quantities that
again we can determine from
equation of state data.
Only V, p and T appear.
So it's minus T dV/dT at
constant p, plus V. And so,
again, this can come from
equation of state data.
And if you do this again for
an ideal gas, let me see.
So we have pV is nRT.
So dV/dT at constant pressure
is just nR over p.
But we can plug that in again
just like we did before.
It's just equal to V over T.
And so dH/dp under our
condition of constant
temperature is just minus T
times V over T plus
V, everything
cancels, and that's zero.
That's our Joule - Thompson
expansion.
That was a constant
enthalpy change.
And again there, too, you saw
an experimental result you
were presented with that says,
well at least to the extent
that it could be measured,
it was obviously
getting very small.
For gases that approach
ideal gas conditions.
Well, there you can see it.
Sure better have gotten
small because in fact
it has to be zero.
Now let's take just
one somewhat
more complicated case.
Let's look at a van
der Waal's gas.
Let's try it with a different
equation of state, that isn't
quite as simple as the
ideal gas case.
So, then p plus a over molar
volume squared times V minus b
molar volume V minus b is
equal to RT, remember?
This was back from the
first or second
lecture in the course.
So, we can separate out p.
It's RT over molar volume minus
b minus a over molar
volume V squared.
And then we can take the
derivative with respect to
temperature, it's just R over
molar volume minus b.
So it's dp/dT at constant V is
just R over V bar minus b.
Well, let's now look, given
this, let's now look in that
case, at what happens to u as a
function of V. For the ideal
gas, we know that u is
volume independent.
It only depends on
the temperature.
But for the van der
Waal's gas, now
it's going to be different.
And that's because this is
different from what it is in
the ideal gas case.
Namely, now du/dV at constant T,
for the van der Waal's gas.
So it's this.
So it's RT over molar
volume minus b.
Minus p, right?
But in fact, if you go back to
the van der Waal's equation of
state, here's RT
over v minus b.
If we put it as minus
b, that's just
equal to a over V squared.
Equals a over molar
volume squared.
But the point is, the main
point is, it's not zero.
It's some number. a over the
molar volume squared. a is a
positive number in the van der
Waal's equation of state.
So this is greater than zero.
In other words, u is a function
of T and V. If we
don't have an ideal gas.
By the way, just to think about
it a little bit, it's a
positive number.
What that means is, I've got my
ideal gas in some container.
There's some energy, some
internal energy.
Now I make the volume bigger.
I allow it to expand.
And the energy changes,
it goes up.
In some sense it's less
favorable energetically.
What's happening there, that a
term in the van der Waal's
equation of state, is describing
interactions,
favorable attractions, between
gas molecules.
The b is describing
repulsions.
Effectively, the
volume changes.
The molar volume is being
changed a little bit by the
fact that if you're really
trying to make things collide
with each other, they can't
occupy the same volume.
And that is being
expressed here.
The a, though is expressing
attraction between molecules
at somewhat longer range.
So now, if you make the
volume bigger, those
attractions die out.
Because the molecules are
farther apart from each other.
So the energy goes up.
Now, you might ask, well why
does it do that, right?
I mean, if the energy is lower
to occupy a smaller volume,
then if I have this room and a
bunch of molecules of oxygen,
and nitrogen and what have you
in the air, and there are weak
attractions between them, why
don't they all just sort of
glum together and find whatever
volume they like.
So that the attractive
forces can exert
themselves a little bit.
Not too close, right?
Not so close that the
repulsions dominate.
Why don't they do that?
What else matters besides any
of those considerations?
What else matters that I haven't
considered in this
little discussion?
Yeah.
What about entropy, right?
If I only worry about
minimizing the
energy, it's true.
They'll stick together
a little bit.
But entropy also matters.
And there's disorder achieved
by occupying the full
available volume.
Many more states possible.
And that will end up winning out
at basically any realistic
temperature where the stuff
really is a gas.
OK.
Next time, what you're going
to see is the following.
It turns out we can express all
these functions in terms
of G, we wouldn't need to choose
G, but it's a very
useful function to choose.
Because of its natural
expression in
terms of T and p.
So we can write any of these
functions in terms of G. Which
means that we can really
calculate all the
thermodynamics in
terms of only g.
It's not necessary to do that,
but it can be quite
convenient.
And then we can say, OK, if we
have many constituents, what
if we have a mixture of stuff?
We can take the derivative of
G with respect to how much
material there is.
With respect to n, the
number of moles.
And if there are one, and two,
and three constituents with
respect to n1, and n2, and n3.
Each individual amount
of stuff.
What that's going to allow us to
do is, if we say, OK I have
a mixture of stuff, how does
the free energy change?
If I change the composition
of the mixture?
If I take something away, or
put something else in?
And we'll be able to determine
equilibrium under those
conditions.
That's very useful for things
like chemical reactions, where
this constituent changes
to this one.
And I can calculate what happens
to G under those
conditions.
And that's what you'll see
starting next time.
And professor Blendi
will be taking over
for that set of lectures.